I, by the way, talk about being fat. I work out so hard. Okay.
I rushed.
Six.
Ice cream sandwiches last night. You ever done that?
You ever done anything like that? You have, have you? Oh, okay. Okay.
Actually that makes me feel much better. Six, bro.
Okay. So you haven't then my producer, literally lied to me in this small room.
You ever done anything like that? He goes, yeah. I said six. He says, no,
which is it, bro? I eight, six. And I, and you know what,
dude, I chose to be done. I could have eight, nine. that.
That's it. I could never stop eating. You know how people are like, Oh,
how about portions? What? Huh? Portions.
Huh? How much did you make?
That's mine. What are you talking about? Portions.
Yo you know how many times I haven't
eaten other people's meals that weren't done to only when
I'm in a professional setting. If I'm with a girl,
if I'm with my mom or brother, gimme that to dude.
What are you talking about? Portions?
How much did you make?
Dude?
My uncles this way too. My dad's not this way. My dad would lead a portion.
The my brother will eat a portion of the portion.
What are you trying to fit in a swimsuit? What is your mind doing?
Gimme all the taste, bro. I'm full here,
but the feels jolly up here. Still.
My tongue is dancing through that flavor is
dancing around my mouth. Yeah,
I'm working on a,
I'm working on filling up a toilet bowl in my bottom
section,
but that food is having a Mardi Gras
party. Dude, the pasta in my mouth is yelling at the sauce,
telling it to show its.
That's how much I want in my mouth.
It's throwing a 40th over the Hill,
birthday party in my mouth and I'm not done inviting people.
Can my friends come? Yes. Are they tasty?
Gimme that two
portions. Come on, dude.
I mean really?
I eat til I feel obviously look at me.
I take, I try to take care of myself. I obviously understand, you know,
I'm lucky I got a fast metabolism, but I also work out very hard. Okay. But bro,
I eat sometimes till I feel you ever eat so much
that you feel so gross where you feel like, you know,
what would top it off? Just getting a dirty suck.
You know what I'm talking about? If, if, if I was, if I so much,
I was so fat that I just sat here and got a dirty suck.
Like after I buy some like, you know,
some like a lawyer,
just a dirty suck from a female lawyer, you know,
that's how much I eat.
I eat so much that I would just sit in a curvy position on my
couch with my Tommy out.
Just getting a dirty suck from a lawyer brow.
That's how much I eat ni naked.
I'll post them by the way. Postmates. Do it all.
Uber eats it and they'll show up to my house.
I'll eat all this with my naked as Dick flopping
around. And then just imagine getting a dirty suck by the way.
I'm not even horny. It's just about the eating. It's about the eating.
It makes you feel better that you ate so much.
You're like if I just get a dirty suck and watch like the
strain on TV and start season in the middle of season
three, just so much disrespect going on,
just disrespect and everything. I'll eat Ali, all the, disrespect.
My body. I'll get a dirty suck and disrespect my partner.
And then watch the strain.
Start with season three and disrespect,
the producers and actors that have worked so hard creating the moment up
until season three,
but just start in the middle in the middle of a show
in the middle of season three, episode five in the middle of it,
just we're all of a sudden where they're like where the w where they're like,
Oh, I don't know what to do. Now that we're surrounded.
And you just start watching,
imagine getting a dirty sock and you ate seven ice cream sandwiches and some
pasta.
It's good to have nights like that, man. I don't mean to be so inspiring,
but it's good to have nights like that. You got to live a little one time.
I saw the rock in an Instagram video, how he was like, I never had in and out,
but I took my cast members to in and out and he drove through and they were
like, Hey, it's the rock?
And he got the burgers and he handed the burgers over for castmates and he
didn't eat the burgers. I know, I know he has cheat days. I've seen it. But bro,
if you drive through in and out, you get a burger,
be disrespectful,
dirty suck, man. They're in a sack there and it's not.